hey dr. Berg here this short video I'm
going to talk about some of the best
hypothyroid supplements and you can take
the problem with most thyroid
supplements is they treat the thyroid
which is the exact opposite thing you
want to do because of this and if this
is very important because most thyroid
cases or hypothyroid cancers are
secondary to something else they're not
usually a problem in the thyroid
directly and so when you treat them with
this or this supplement or iodine
whatever you don't really get anywhere I
have a ton of people who are taking
thyroid medication actual hormones and
they're still tired and they're still
fat it's not working so chances are
there's something else causing it and
these are the two most common things
that will cause a thyroid problem number
one is a lack of bile b.i le5 is the
fluid that comes out of liver and it
helps to break down fats it's like the
detergent that breaks down the grease on
your hands
but we have it in our liver and without
bile you get bloating burping nauseous
you get right shoulder pain because the
livers on the right side so you and you
might get headaches and then because you
don't absorb vitamin A you get dry eyes
and night vision issues you don't absorb
any of the fat soluble vitamins like
vitamin D so there goes the calcium it
might get some depression and when you
eat you're not satisfied because without
this bile you can't pull the nutrients
but the biggest thing is that you t4 out
of the thyroid that's the inactive
thyroid hormone goes to the liver and
converts to t3 t3 is the active form
that does all the work
so what probably happening is you don't
have enough file you can't convert this
thyroid and you end up having thyroid
symptoms but never really get anywhere
because you don't have this digestive
thing tweaked so if this is your
situation very simple remedy you can do
it's called bio formula gallbladder
formula which has bile salts in it and
it has a lot of other things that will
help lubricate the duct
help dissolve any stones or crud in
there and it supports the liver so this
would be good for that gall bladder
formula to help you give you a little
bile to lubricate the colon especially
if you don't even have a gall bladder
anymore so you need some bile you can
get some violet to grocery store I mean
the healthy store as well I just had the
one that has a couple other things that
for the liver anyway we want this
conversion and then number two the other
situation that will cause a hypothyroid
is high estrogen and that's called
estrogen dominant and that's because the
ovaries are pumping out too much
estrogen so it's really a high per ovary
yeah so that estrogen that builds up
will kind of cut down and block the
thyroid from functioning so anytime you
have high estrogen you're going to have
a low thyroid and that's why women that
go through pregnancy the end up with a
lot of thyroid problems afterwards so if
we want to support the ovary directly we
want we don't want to support the
hormone we want to support that gland I
use the product it's called ovary
support formula and this product tends
to help normalize function of the ovary
but again we're not treating diseases go
see your doctor for that this is just
new trishal support to help maintain a
healthy endocrine system so those are
the two tips that I have for supplements
and you may want to try them and I think
you're going to get a little bit better
results